last night uh finally more than a half a
year after the unarmed ashley babbitt
was shot by a capital police officer
in the capitol building the name of the
shooter was made public
and not because it was officially
released by anybody in a position of
authority as has happened in every other
controversial police shooting in recent
memory
they would have been fined just letting
his name never make it officially into
the public even though it'd been
circulating online for some time now in
this case uh it was because the officer
himself michael byrd is his name
decided to speak out
fortunately for lieutenant michael byrd
who shot ashley babbitt in the chest at
near point-blank range as she was
climbing through a broken door he was
able to face the public with the help of
a very powerful pr team otherwise known
as the entire mainstream media doesn't
even have to pay them pay pay them it's
a pretty sweet deal
lester holt of nbc news sat down with
bird to
pitch him softballs and give him a
chance to extol his own virtue and
courage which he was more than willing
and eager to do
early on in the exchange in fact
byrd declared that he showed quote the
utmost courage in reference to himself
by shooting an unarmed woman in the
chest
listen to this can you give us the
nature of some of those threats
they
talked about you know killing me uh
cutting off my head
you know very vicious and cruel
things racist things
there were some racist attacks as well
it's all disheartening because i know i
was doing my job given the nature of the
threats that you describe do you have
any concern about showing your face and
identifying of course i do
that is a very vital point
and it's something that uh
is frightening i believe i showed the
utmost carriage on january 6 and it's
time for me to do that now oh i'm sorry
he actually credits himself with courage
twice so he has the utmost courage on
january 6 by shooting an unarmed woman
in the chest he also has the um most
courage just by sitting down in front of
a friendly media who is ready to
celebrate him and accept everything that
he says there's a lot of courage there
as well now what led into that is he was
being asked about um the threats the the
response he's gotten after his name
leaked on on social media and he claimed
that he's getting all these threats
people threatening to cut off his head
he claims he claims anyway
and you see a lester halt there again
part of the pr team leading him coaching
him alongside racist threats was there
racist threats too
oh yeah sure oh yeah racism also
we haven't seen any of that we have no
evidence of it but that's what he tells
us
at least nobody can accuse him of having
an over over abundance of humility at
least
and byrd then goes on to explain uh what
led up to him deciding to pull the
trigger on that day he does claim
he claims that he issued repeated
warnings
and that's one really important part of
this did he say anything did he issue
any warnings before firing his weapon
he says that he did
but that's not substantiated by any
video that we've ever been allowed to
see
or any witnesses that we've heard from
it seems like you probably could
substantiate that
i'm sure on the other side of that door
there's some security footage security
cameras all in that building
you might be able to hear some of that
but we haven't we haven't they haven't
released that to us
we haven't heard from any witness who
says that they heard him yelling
and giving a warning but he says that he
did
and uh we'll listen to that part here
he says officers barricaded the door
what he considered the last line of
defense i had been yelling and screaming
as loud as i was please stop get back
get back
stop we had our weapons drawn
bird only his hand and gun visible
targeted a figure trying to climb
through a window
he fired a single fatal shot hitting
ashley babbitt she was 35 years old an
air force veteran trump supporter and q
anon follower i was
taking a tactical stance you're
ultimately hoping that
your commands will be complied with
and unfortunately they were not when you
fired
what could you see
where were you aiming you're taught to
aim for center mass
the subject was sideways
and i could not see her full motion of
her hands or anything
um
so
i guess her movement
you know
caused
the uh discharge to
to fall where it did and what did you
think this individual was doing at that
at that well she was posing a threat
to united states house of
representatives
uh now you note there how they also
included the bit about how she was a q
anon follower
not sure what that has to do with
anything now we're told that
um george floyd
being a violent felon
who uh uh rushed into a woman's home and
put a gun to her stomach and robbed her
in front of her kids that that history
those biographical details about george
floyd are not relevant at all in fact if
you bring them up you're a horrible
person you're a racist even somehow for
simply bringing that up it's got nothing
to do with anything we're told
and yet the fact that ashley babbitt
believed in some kooky
uh q anon thing what does that have to
do with anything
did did he know that
is that we're always told about george
floyd well yeah he might have done all
these horrible things and been this
violent uh terrible
scumbag of a person but but the officer
didn't know that didn't know that
that doesn't get him off the hook
well what did what information about
ashley babbitt did
michael byrd have
none
now this leads us to perhaps the most
revealing point in the interview holt
asks him if the fact that he didn't know
whether she was armed altered his
decision-making at all
and listen to his answer because it's
very important here
her family points out that she was not
armed
that's correct the fact that you weren't
aware whether she was armed or not did
that alter the decision-making
it did not what should we make of the
fact that there were other officers in
other
potentially life-threatening situations
who didn't use their service weapons
that day
i'm sure it was a terrifying situation
i can only control
my reaction my training my level
expertise that would be upon them to
speak for themselves
former president trump has has talked
about you and this and this incident
he says she was murdered
what does it
feel like to hear that from a former
president
well it's disheartening if he was in the
room or anywhere
and i'm responsible for him
i was prepared to do the same thing for
him and his family
what does it feel like what does it feel
like to be to be
to be called a murderer
yeah what does it feel like well it must
not feel great
can we get that question to all of all
of the other cops
in every single shooting that the blm's
been upset about they've all been called
murderers
from the very top
what about the copy shot mikaya bryant
saving someone's life in the process
saving the life of a young black woman
by shooting someone who's trying to stab
her to death
some crazed lunatic with a butcher knife
he was called a murderer
by many many very prominent people
including in the white house if i
remember correctly
can we sit down with him say how does
that make you feel
when you were when you were directly
saving someone's life and you were
called you were accused of racist murder
now that question doesn't ask we only
ask it of of this guy here
now on the on the topic of whether or
not she was armed notice what what
uh officer byrd does not say
he does not say
that he thought she was armed
he doesn't say that he couldn't see her
hands and thought maybe there was a gun
he doesn't say
that he thought she had a bomb in her
backpack or something
he says that he wasn't sure if she was
armed or not and he shot anyway that's
what he just said
now i want you to imagine any other
police officer from any other shooting
in memory
offering a justification like that
well did you think he was armed i i
didn't really know
but you shot him yeah
what kind of reception do you think that
would receive
and we'll return to that point in a
moment but let's wrap up with one more
clip holt uh briefly puts bird in a
mildly uncomfortable position by asking
him about an incident a few years ago
where bird left his loaded service
weapon in a bathroom
and walked away clearly demonstrating
you would think a certain uh
recklessness that may have played a role
in what transpired on january 6 but byrd
simply shrugs that off and says that it
was a mistake and it was dealt with and
halt doesn't push him on it then at the
end bird who has already bragged of his
incredible
steadfast courage
makes this claim let's listen
multiple investigations have now upheld
byrd's actions on january 6th
capitol police in their
press release after exonerating you said
your actions potentially save members
and staff from serious injury and
possible death
what was it like to hear those words to
see those words
those words meant a lot because that's
exactly what i did
on that day
that was my mission
that was what i
prepared for
and
it's
it's rewarding and refreshing to hear
that
oh well i'm glad you're rewarded and
refreshed this is grotesque it's just
disgusting you think you can't be any
more
uh disgusted by the media but then they
they managed to stoop to new lows every
single day
he killed a woman and the whole
interview is about how he how does that
make you feel how does it make you must
make you feel good to hear to hear that
the capitol police did an investigation
of themselves and discovered that they
themselves hadn't done anything wrong
well that settles that i suppose
in fact he's quoted michael bird is
quoted by nbc news as these aren't the
words you hear in that in that clip but
they quote him
in their article um
that is him saying that he saved quote
countless lives
countless lives
he's not even saying that he thought he
was saving lives at the time
that would be one thing
he's saying that even now looking back
on it in hindsight he did save all of
those lives
i mean how we know that ashley babbitt
we know now
some of this he might not have known at
the time but now we know that ashley
babbitt was a five foot two inch unarmed
female
and even now he's saying by killing her
he saved countless lives what was she
gonna do
was she gonna bust through the window
and murder dozens of armed cops with her
bare hands
would she uma thurman and kill bill some
kind of trained assassin
the claim from bird is absurd on its
face the whole interview was absurd
again grotesque
and impossible to imagine any other
police officer ever receiving that kind
of treatment or being given this sort of
opportunity by nbc or any other media
outlet at all
and that's one important point to be
made about this of course before we talk
about whether babbitt's shooting was
justified based on the objective facts
of the case it is inarguable that the
people defending it every single one of
them would be exploding with outrage if
she had a different skin color and a
different political affiliation all of
these defund the police champions have
finally discovered one unarmed shooting
of a civilian that they support which
only proves what we already knew
that all of their concern over police
brutality really has nothing to do with
police brutality at all
and i have and i am not aware i don't
think it's an exaggeration to say that
none of these people
have
come to the defense of ashley babbitt
not a single one
that perf
and they believe by their own
professions that police officers are
many of them serial killers basically
they they they only get into this line
of work because they want to bully and
kill people and be oppressors that's
what they say
and and normally when there's a shooting
of a of a civilian
and the person is unarmed
right that's all that's all the
information they need they were unarmed
and period you don't kill them
we have been told this so many times
and yet in this case it's not even that
they look the other way they celebrate
it
they don't care about police brutality
they don't care about abuses by the
state they don't care about anything or
anyone they don't even care about the
dead criminals whose faces they paint in
murals on walls it's only about the
ideology the dead bodies are vehicles
for their ideological agenda
now they'll deny this of course and say
that somehow this is different ashley
babbitt was in a government building
they'll say she was trespassing she was
warned allegedly
but almost all of the blm martyrs were
also warned repeatedly to stop and they
didn't george floyd was warned jacob
blake was warned ray shard brooks was
worn they were all warned
michael brown was certainly warned
and as far as government buildings if
that somehow makes all the difference
and i don't see why it should
i mean is there something sacred about a
government building
if they've been doing this in a in some
sort of private building whether that
that that changes things why
are the lives of uh of congressmen and
politicians are they are they actually
more important than the lives of just
regular people is that what you're
saying apparently that's that's what
we're being told
but if that does make all the difference
well blm militants invaded a police
station and burned it to the ground
with cops fleeing for their lives they
assaulted a federal courthouse for
months on end if any cop had fired a
single shot at any of them and they
didn't not one shot fired
through all of those months
but if they had
there would have been eruptions of
outrage
blm would have burned cities to the
ground in response
even more cities anyway
so we know that that
is the case with with these people we
know that that's the the
hypocrisy here and it actually is
hypocrisy in this case that's an
appropriate use of the term
because a hypocrite is someone who
pretends to believe something pretends
to hold a conviction or principle that
they don't actually hold
and that describes blm and defund the
police to a t
but just looking at the objective facts
on the ground the objective facts of the
case
was can we say with everything that we
know now there's still a lot that we're
not being told
there's still a lot of evidence that
we're not being allowed to see a lot of
footage that we're not being given many
supposed eyewitnesses that we've never
heard from
but based on everything that we know and
seen can we can we say that ashley
babbitt shooting was justified and i
would say even more now that i don't see
how that could possibly be the case
and i think there are a few points
a few things that point to that and many
of them were touched on in the interview
but they weren't they didn't dwell on it
they just moved on one of them
is that there were a whole lot of cops
there that day and not a single other
one of other cop felt the need to fire
their weapon
i think that really tells you something
he was the only one and he claims he
saved countless lives
if he needed to fire a shot to save
countless lives
then then countless lives should have
been should have been taken elsewhere
because all these other cops weren't
firing any shots
so that doesn't make a lot of sense
we also know that that ashley babbitt
was surrounded
by armed police officers
behind her coming up the steps
uh with with rifles and and uh
and on the other side of that door he
wasn't the only one in that in that
hallway you can even see that on the
clip
did he need did he have to resort to
lethal force
in order to stop her when she is an
unarmed woman
surrounded by police officers with their
guns trained on her
i don't see how that could possibly be
the case
could he not have run up as she was
climbing through the door and pulled her
down
and put her in cuffs and detained her
could he not have easily done that
if he had said something like
well i thought she had a gun i thought i
saw one
yeah then it would just be a matter of
do we believe the claim that he actually
thought he saw a gun and there'd be no
way for us to know we don't really know
we can't be inside his head in a moment
but he's not even saying that he's not
even saying i thought she had a gun
he is saying bye i didn't know
and that to me is the final fact that
really
settles she was murdered and it's more
clear than it ever was before
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content